good morning everyone good afternoon or
good evening depending on where you are
in the world thanks for joining us for
this aws webinar with tarun dave
aws security identity and access
management
security of course is essential for any
application but when that application is
hosted on a public cloud security
becomes vital
so the popularity of amazon web services
as the preferred public cloud is largely
due to its reputation as the most secure
cloud platform on the market aws
identity and access management plays a
key role in providing secure and
controlled access to aws resources so in
this session
tarun is going to explain iam users root
groups roles
and so forth to better secure your
information with aws now if you are not
familiar with tarun let me fill you in a
little bit he is an evangelist for aws
an aws certified solutions architect
associate with more than 15 years of
work experience as a consultant a
technical architect and a project leader
throughout his career he has managed
teams as large as 30 or more working
with various global clients including
the large mncs of india and the us and
now he is working with startups and
organizations to help them design and
migrate their apps to aws
he's also an active blogger and a
content writer on this topic and as a
trainer he has conducted training
sessions for over 800 participants
on the aws solution architect associate
level exam
so we're very lucky to have him here and
he's going to definitely uh
be uh
peeling the curtains away from the
mystery of aws for you before we get
started i just want to make sure
everybody's hearing us okay and
familiarize you all with your dashboard
so go ahead and take a look at the
dashboard and find the questions module
that's the place for you not the chat
module
but the questions module go ahead and
find that questions module and type in
there for me if you would just say hello
to tarun so that
he knows you're here and that you're
happy he's uh ready to start and you're
looking forward to hearing some good
stuff there we go thank you martin thank
you uncool
i see deanna from austin i think deanna
you were with us a couple of days ago
too if i'm not mistaken
um
so great that's terrific thank you for
doing that that way i know that you're
hearing me and i'm not just talking into
the darkness
the questions module will be your best
friend as we go we've got about a
45-minute presentation today
if you have questions go ahead and type
them into this uh questions module
we will loop back around after the
presentation and get through as many
questions as we possibly can but go
ahead and type them in there and we'll
cue them up and and and consolidate them
where we need to if we have a group of
people all asking the same thing and
sometimes that happens if you hear
something super awesome and uh that you
want to share on your social channels
feel free to do so go ahead and live
tweet or facebook or what have you you
can use the hashtag sl webinars and let
folks know about all the awesomeness
that you're learning and make them all
jealous that they're not here and maybe
they'll join us next time
that's all you need to hear from me i'm
going to turn this over to our presenter
tarun dave
and go ahead and grab yourselves a cup
of coffee or a cup of tea or a glass of
wine whatever's appropriate and sit back
and
my friend tarun is going to lay the
wisdom down good morning sir how are you
hey hey chip thanks a lot very good
evening to you
also welcome all to simply learn and
thanks chief again for giving a
wonderful introduction about me as well
as engaging participants
i welcome everyone again and today we
are going to talk about a very
interesting topic
aws security with identity and excess
management
now we all know the public cloud is the
flavor of the uh this now decade now
everybody started moving others i would
say cloud is the flavor that ticket and
everybody started moving to the cloud
and now amazon rules that cloud world
when you talk about the cloud everybody
always when you ask anyone what is cloud
and then one thing would be oh it's not
secure
that was around five years back or
multiple years back i would say
it's not same anymore
we would
we would see some of the mysteries of
the cloud but we would try to solve some
of those metrics
with amazon web services identity and
access management
today
we are going to learn about what is iam
you would also learn about i am users
groups and policies i am rules and
authentications and some of the best
practices when you want to work with
amazon the security best practice are
the way to go for you
but before we begin cheap has already
introduced me i am tarun david
i'm myself an aws solution architect
trainer where i've conducted more than
30 plus training sessions for 800 plus
participants
on amazon solution architect associate
level exam
and that makes me i'm also a double
solution architect associate level
i'm having total 16 plus here for it
experience after that last five years
i'm working with amazon
i've worked with the leading eminences
of india on research cloud projects i
keep on doing blogging content creation
for amazon
currently as a full-time role i would
say i'm working as a aw solution
architect and mentor i'm maintaining a
few startups some of the organization
i'm working as in a consulting architect
i'm involved in designing architecting
managing infrastructure for large as
well as small-scale applications
as a trainer i'm doing this training
since more than four years and
responsible for designing content
workshop management assignment quiz
the most important thing i'm passionate
about amazon amazon is one of my love i
always love to explore more and more
about amazon i keep on telling people
amazon is like an ocean and you always
need to keep on swimming across that
because there would not be an end
because there are so many things every
time amazon keeps on adding to learn
about that
as part of that i've also written a few
white papers articles on amazon too
so that's about me
but
what is i am
it's not i am it's i am it's identity
and excess management
so let's start with some example
start with a small startup i'll take an
example my hope is a
startup where
currently it's been formed by three
people only so that three people they
would love their fancy titles all cxos
so one would be ceo one would be cto one
would be c develop they would be
basically they all would be doing
programming they all would be doing the
development they would be doing
marketing they would be responsible for
everything
when you are a small company you are a
startup amazon is a very lucrative for
you it comes handy easy to use cheaper
pay-as-you-go model scalable everything
what you want would amazon would deliver
to you
so it's no wonder the startup would
always go with this
amazon as a one of the option now when
they hosted everything on amazon
what is the thing they would be doing
generally when you register with amazon
you would be registering with your email
id and amazon you would define a
password over there that is known as
your root account
a root account means with which account
you have registered with amazon now you
believe or not the same account is valid
for the all amazon shopping also whether
you shop on amazon.com or amazon.com the
save account is valid and why is also
true if you already have an account
registered with amazon
you can use that with aws too
so root account you would be using to
register with
your amazon account start over there
start using various services you would
be doing that
this would be okay
since you have a smaller team
what if the team starts growing
team starts growing the ceo would be
adding more and more product team the
product management team project
management team the cto would be adding
more development testing production team
the ceo would be also writing editor
admin
everybody would love to have access to
amazon they would have their own purpose
it's not for the application but
something they would have some access
for the building somebody would like to
see somebody would like to see for the
backups somebody would like to see for
the deployment somebody would like to
access for the testing everybody would
have a different kind of requirement to
access amazon
now the challenge starts here
if you give root account access the main
account access to everyone how would it
work for you you would have no tracking
how does this work for you who is going
to change what he somebody might though
he might not have a million intentions
but he might do something uh
by mistake he might kill your production
instance also
this all could happen
you need to secure your amazon resources
it's also very important
how do you provide
these people
right kind of access so they
access amazon systems in a correct way
and your production system or water
system stays intact
amazon i am
comes handy for that
aws i am
enables you to securely control access
to amazon services and resource for your
users now this is a very important word
to note
i am especially when you want to
provide secure access to amazon services
and resources for your users this is a
very important thing what is so special
here
for example you have hosted a web
application in amazon
easy to service now if you don't know
ec2 you always have a chance join us in
our aws tech essential course you would
learn more about that on almost 30
services of amazon we will be giving you
an overview introduction learning about
those services
so you could always learn about that
amazon in our course coming back to
ec2 would be a one hosting service
offered by amazon where you it's like a
virtual server in the cloud
you would always think oh in that server
if i want to ever access that only
somebody can access my
app server somebody can do the
configuration file would that be
possible remember this is not the case
of iam
i am is a service when you want to work
with amazon as a service
so you want to amazon has almost 50
offerings i would start with easy to ebs
rds s3 ppc elb auto scaling
cloud front cloud watch elastic load
balancer 2
im and milling
and many more
you keep on going i may got tired also
remembering each and every one
all those services would have a
different kind of a purpose some service
would be for networking some service
would be for storage some service for
the backup some size for the security
some service for the services there
would be different aspect available
so think of that in your organ agent
everybody would be accessing amazon for
different purpose for example your cfo
team might access it for the billing
purpose only
right your hr team may or azure team
outcome at the last your testing team
would access the only
tasting part only they would be just
having a read only access the
development team would have only access
to the development service not to full
access
your ist might have access only to your
backup parts so they need to take the
backup regularly
every team would have a different kind
of a purpose a different kind of a
service they are going to use within
amazon
i am is for that purpose
you can create various users within im
and give each user different kind of an
access
it gives you lots of security
why
because now you are the users the user
would have only restricted access so one
user logs in and he can perform only
production task one user can log in and
he can see only billing tasks if you are
a hr user hr user would log in can only
do this iam task where the duty is to
create the users and manage the
permission
to managing the resources
one would be only for the backup part
one would be the testing one would be
for the uh database management there
would be different kind of roles for the
you users would be doing various kind of
activities
i am helps you to define those kind of a
users
you create the users you give this kind
of a permission of that users to the
various people
so various amazon service access you can
give to them
now think over if we go back to our
previous slide
i just go back there
if you thought about now this is see you
at the two major team heads city where
the three major teammates but now
imagine each teammate whatever multiple
users is part of that development
whatever 30 people testing whatever 10
people production would might have 20
people that means you have to create a
30 plus 10 plus 20 60 users you have to
create
that you can anyway create but does it
mean that you have to go to each and
every user and define a permission for
them you would go in development and say
oh you have a permission for only
development
now the
there is a development guy in
development guy b and development guy c
for each and every user you'll be able
to define the permission
it's going to be awesome because in
future if you change permission what
development team can do you have to go
to all 30 users
that's not what the ideal case for you
and that's why
im offers the concept called groups
group is nothing but the collection of
the users
you can add group you can add users to
multiple groups you can think of it's
like a department
the person in the same department would
have a same kind of duties
exactly same thing you add those users
to a groups and those
you assign policy or permission only at
group level
all users belonging to that group would
have that permission
so users and groups
now comes the one of the most powerful
thing which is getting popular within
amazon is roles
roles are like groups only
but they have a different purpose
altogether
rules are for special entities or you
can say they are like a pseudo groups
but dummy groups
what is it exactly we will see in our
upcoming slides
you create all this thing now you define
the policies what each user or role or
group would be having access to that is
what your policy would be doing
once you define that policy you can
assign a policy to the user or group or
rule
based on that they would be having a
various access
what a organization has grown
tremendously now our ten thousand
employees out of that eight thousand are
doing development work
do i need to create those eight thousand
people and for all the centers and i
have to make those groups and everything
that's the tiresome job
amazon offers
identity federation service
that is where
you can have your own organization
directly service like activity directory
and have something which can integrate
with amazon
and give you secure access of your
amazon resources so just by logging to
your identity services or
directory service of your organization
you can define what kind of a rules or
what kind of a permission you would have
okay someone is saying he's having some
kind of a noise
i'm not sure if everybody is having the
same
then
we also have a fine grained access to
amazon resources the major purpose of
this is you get very fine grain access
to amazon resources like
if you want to assign someone you can
only launch an instance you want to
assign someone you can only
take the backup you want to send someone
you can only do the database management
this kind of a
very fine grain access you can give to
the various resources
that's what is possible for the i am and
the icing on the cake is
whole service is free of cost you don't
need to pay anything to amazon you can
achieve the security thing with amazon
without paying anything to aws
by the way if you have questions
you can always keep on posting your
questions here
just with regard to the just hey tyrone
just with regard to the noise i think it
might be a mic placement thing we're
still it's we seem to be picking up
maybe there's some rubbing of your
clothing on the microphone or is maybe
there's a little wind or something but
that's that's just
let me adjust that just a moment
is it better now
yes that sounds pretty good
yeah i don't hear it now
there you go great
great
okay so we're talking about i am now how
do you work in the i am
you have to create first step would be
you would be creating a user
now once you've created the users the
second step would be you might be at
creating groups
add that user to a group
a single user keep off multiple groups
so for example
[Music]
we're losing you now i'm sorry i don't
know if you made a change to your
microphone but now you're
we're i'm afraid we're losing you all
together now i don't know if you
switched microphones or what but we got
rid of the noise in the background but
now you're cutting out i'm sorry
oh is it my voice is not clear now is it
still
well that sounds great right now but
when you talk
when you were just speaking a moment ago
you you dropped out on us completely
there for for a moment so
uh we'll continue to move
it
perfect if anybody finds problem do let
me know um not sure if that was a
temporary thing uh yep
i think we're good i'm sorry go ahead
perfect yeah so a user can be part of
multiple groups and that gives you an
advantage also because if you have to
create a policy you create policy only
at a group level and add various users
to different groups and manage them
after all this policy assignment the
user can access amazon resources they
can log into aws console and they can
manage a part of that
that's how you achieve the security
don't give everyone everything give them
what they
deserve
so there is a different group who would
have a different kind of access give
them only that kind of access only
then let's talk about this users groups
little bit more about that
you would be creating users as per your
access requirement because you might
have requirement you would have liked to
have a user for the development you
might have a user for the
testing you might have user for the
backup
you would be creating various users for
that
each user would have their own kind of a
credentials they would have their own
keys they would have a password they
would have tokens to access amazon
resources
even
they would ever separate aws login
console
because your normal login control or aws
console is for all aws account users
when you go to iam users they would have
their separate login console also
so each user would have their own
credentials they would have also you can
assign them individual permissions they
can part of the group or they can work
independently also
and this permission can be as powerful
as a root user
or as minimal as a no access
so you can define various kind of
permissions and the user would be access
to resources
when i go to the group this is how the
group would look like so this is my my
hope like the testing team the
development team the team keeps screwing
each user you have to add to the group
and for that group level you would be
assigning various permissions so you
would be assigning permission for the
group people
and advantage is if john is part of the
testing you would have all the access
what is different at the testing level
now you can also add john to development
group also
then john can access something what
testing team can do even he can access
what development team can do also
that's how the group thing would work
for you
advantage is you can easily manage
permissions
and this permission is union of all so
one user is part of multiple groups you
would have access of all the group
permissions different for each group
advantage you have to apply change at
only single place you change a policy
you apply only one place it's managed
for all the users of the group
and you can always make multiple groups
based on your
requirement now when you want to work
with the amazon you have to think about
this
who is going to access this
again
i re i tried the same thing
i am is for giving secure access to
amazon resources
now when you want to give the secure
access you decide who is going to access
all this
now
even if he is going to access what all
things is going to access is he going to
access ec2 rds s3 elb
don't worry this all are the core
service of amazon
and you would also know what an action
he would be doing within amazon now what
election would be whether he is going to
start an instant view is going to
terminate things he's going to take the
backup he's going to do delete part
what kind of action that person is going
to do
you want to control better you can
always add more condition saying
what time is he going to get so when is
he going to access
from where from which ip address is he
going to access
how is he going to access so for which
resource he's going to access you can
define all these conditions and that
would help you to define an iam policy
a policy is nothing but the kind of
rules to define for either user or group
or role which entitles them to access of
various amazon services
if you want to get a some analogy
you have a windows machine now windows
machine you would be adding various
users one user would be administrator
one user would be the
guest user one might be a normal users
there would be multiple users now how do
you define administrator you would also
define certain kind of a permission for
that user
when you define
role for that role also you would be or
you would say he's a guest and he can
only see certain part of the things he
would not have a certain kind of access
how do you defend that's what you
defined in a policy exactly same concept
here
but it is not at os level here this is
at i am level i am assuming 50 plus
services for various services there are
various actions we are performing
and for all those action you define a
policy
so here you identify which permissions
to be assigned
you would also say create a policy you
would also use ready policy templates
so amazon also gives you ready-to-use
policies so you don't want to create
your own policy you can use ready policy
you want to create your own policy you
can do that amazon also provides a ready
to uh or policy creation tools which you
can use
now after creation assign that policy to
a user group or role
advantage is you have the granular level
control
very
finer level control you can define what
all the person can access and what he
cannot do that
very easy to manage
the policy is always in json format json
stands for javascript object notation
it's in json formatter easy to manage
those changes
you don't want to reinvent the build
amazon has ready templates why do you go
and create your own use the ready one
you can create policy for various amazon
resource like s3 im sqs and all other
the policy is what entitles you to
access various resources
whether you are part of a you are an
individual user or this user is part of
a group or there is something wrong
the policy assigned to that user group
or role
entitles that user group or role to
perform certain action
you want to define certain kind of
conditions you can always do that
like you want to give an example my
development team can access only micro
and small instance now micro means 1 gb
ram machine small means 2 gb ram machine
you want to define if there is a my
development team they can work only with
1gb and 2gb ram machine they cannot work
with the larger machine but there's a
testing team they can only access test
machines not any other machine
if i have my backup team they can take
only
backup part but they cannot do any
creation part if there is a production
team they would have all access to ec2
but they do not have the finance and
billing access i don't want to show how
much i am spending on amazon it's my
worry
if i have a storage team they would be
responsible for my amazon internet-based
storage call s3 so you can define all
this kind of a policy and permission
which could entitle the user to access
various kind of resources at a major
level and you would say what is the use
of this when you start using amazon as i
said amazon is an ocean and you know
when you start using you'd find it's not
the one person would manage that there
would be lots of services and you need
to give them the various kind of access
that's how the aws would be very helpful
to you so these are the some of the
simple policies i have listed down for
you
so for here
a policy would have a statement as a
first thing that's what everything would
be part of a statement
then it would be a
sequence id or statement id that is what
the unique number given by amazon
apart from that you can define
what all kind of action user can perform
right here you can say
user is allowed to attach volume create
snapshot create volume describe snapshot
detach volume kind of action he can
perform
but whether he can or not that is
mentioned here whether you are allowing
him
or denying him
you want to add conditions you can add
conditions also in the condition block
so this is the kind of a policy in json
format which would help you to define
what are the kind of resources you can
access
within that resource also which all
action you can perform everything you
can define as part of a policy
as i said before i want to give an
analogy when you take the analogy of
your windows machine
you create a user and for that each user
you would be defining certain kind of a
policy or resource access
exactly same thing you are doing here
where you are giving the user access
then comes the iam roles
roles are getting very popular within
amazon
they are a very very important part of
the amazon
what is the role doing
an i am role is very similar to a group
or a user
here it's like an aws identity with a
permission policy that determine
what that identity can do and cannot do
in amazon
you would say it looks almost like group
or user because
every time you are saying you are
entitling something to perform something
so here also role is doing same
what is the difference in the role if
god has a permission that you a group
would have permission what does it do
differently
here instead of being uniquely
associated with a person
a role is assumed by anyone who needs it
now this is a tricky statement
why would you need this kind of a rule
rule
if i want to give
another analogy
which you a user or group is for the
living thing
like a human interaction would come that
is where the user or group would be
coming in a picture
but when you want to work with the
non-living thing
role would come in a picture
and now you would say you are me making
me confused
why the non-living thing would work on
the iam
or amazon
take an example
you have written a program
within java ruby python somewhere
programming language
which
uploads data to amazon s3 now amazon s3
is a storage system so you would think
of
it would be uploading data to the amazon
s3
the most popular use case of the amazon
s3r or rather now there were
is dropbox instagram
when you upload a file into dropbox
eventually that was getting stored in
amazon s3 when you were before instagram
went to facebook you upload any file or
any photo to instagram that is being
stored to the amazon s3
so internally a program
calls amazon service and uploads data to
there
now that program needs to know
where should i upload
and does that
at the same time amazon service also
needs to know whether the program which
is making a call to me is having access
or not others people will misuse anybody
would start flooding data at your end
that's why the role would be playing a
row key here
what you can do is you can have a
virtual servers machines or various
accounts where you assign that role to
them
they become like a sudo group or sudo
user
they would be assuming a role
a virtual machine would now assume a
rule
and
that rule says
this is having an access to amazon s3
now this role is being assumed by
virtual server
that server would have access to amazon
s3
so this way if you see the analogy it's
like a pseudo or dummy
group which is being assumed by some
non-living thing non-living thing would
be your programming language could be
some machine could be some different
amazon account
or
if you have written a code which wants
to upload data to the amazon directly
without even having an im user
you can do that using rules
amazon supports a concept called web
identity federation
where it supports facebook
google
amazon and xaml based saml sample-based
authentication mechanism
which allows to upload data
without getting registered with amazon
so it's a complete separate topic
we might be talking a little bit more
about during a tech essential course but
coming back to our i am rolls part
role is where
it would be uniquely identical angle
associating you with certain non-living
thing or you can think of a program or a
machine or account over there
so you use the role to delegate access
to users applications or
services a role is essentially a set of
permissions that would grant access to
actions and resources in amazon
right so it's a kind of at the end role
would have a permission where you would
say you are having a permission to
perform
upload the data to amazon s3 so that
permission is the first
assigned to role and that role is
assigned to an virtual machine
so eventually a virtual machine is
having access to s3
why do you need the role in this world
the biggest advantage is the better
security mechanism
before the
existence of role
people were doing programming with
amazon
what were they doing
amazon offers
a concept called access key and secret
access key this is like your username
and password only
which would be you have to put inside
your code to get authenticated by amazon
but that's not secure
if someone gets your keys
he can always log into your account and
would misuse that
why would you put a password and things
in your code
with role you don't need to put any
username password inside the code rather
put the code in a server which is having
a role assigned
now since the server is assuming that
role
it can perform without having keys
in addition
roll automatically keeps rotating keys
every few hours so that way
it would be much secure also
if i show you a few use cases of the
rule
these are the some of the use cases of
the rules
i'll start with the first rule would be
cross account permission
let's understand you have a testing
account now in amazon you have created
you have
created two separate accounts completely
you have not created you users you
created two separate accounts one is for
the testing one is for the production
another is for the development
now testing team says when i am trying
to develop or i am trying to test
something it is failing
development team says oh it's not
failing here for me
then you would say okay then do one
thing access my data
you can give
tasting account
access of your certain
data this would be kind of a one-way
traffic where testing can access only
this data they would not be able to
access anything else
so here one account is having us some
kind of access
in the same case think of
when you have
a production account
now
production account has to fade certain
codes or data from the development
in that case you can also provide them
excess of your development account or
vice versa if development account needs
to fetch certain
database schemas
or live data some of the things they
need to fetch
you can provide access to this account
also
how does this work for here there would
be two separate accounts if you see the
right hand side image there would be two
separate accounts
here you would be creating a rule
and assigning this role excess of
separate aws account so you create this
role and you assign this
role access of this aws account
now this role would make a call there
using amazon security token service it
would generate a temporary key that's a
access key secret access key and token
which is valid for a few hours so
henceforth any
calls this account is making to next
account it would send all these tokens
keys everything part of that which would
be authorized by the second account and
allows them to access
second and one of the very important
cases
the identity federation
when we talk about this
identity federation what happens here
in the case of identity federation
you would see
admin on the left-hand side the admin
will be creating a role that grants
access to photo bucket so you want to
create a user which is having
access to some amazon bucket where you
can upload your photos or the some files
anything like dropbox case or the
instagram case
now
developer would be launching a
amazon ec2 machine that's a virtual
server
which would be having this role assigned
developer whoever deployed his
application on that virtual machine
now
application would make call to security
token service would get the credentials
now whenever someone this code
application is trying to upload the code
it would always pass this temporarily
credentials like access key secretary
key
along with that which would authorize by
amazon and allows you to work without
giving your own keys
because this is a temporary key
if you think on another example which we
are talking about the identity
federation
where you want to allow a user
to
put data directly to dynamodb take the
case of the pokemon go i'm sure that's
also favorable favor of the month
everybody's trying to find the pokemon
now when you have pokemon go application
and you want to say that whenever i find
a pokemon i want to store in the
database so that would be stored in
amazon's own database called dynamodb
now people are playing on the mobile
application right
when he wants to put the data in your
application directly without bringing
your application server or anything
rather the application directly wants to
call the database
would that be possible
you would say that would not work
because how would the database know how
would database authorize the person
amazon offers amazon cognito as part of
iam
which would allow
to perform this
where what you have to do is
ask the user that do you want to push
your pokemon or you want to store your
pokemon to your my database okay do one
thing
log in with your facebook amazon google
id oh that everybody would do
once he logs in
your application the mobile application
would make a call to amazon server
get a temporary key access key secret
access key using those facebook or
google based authentication
and
then it would allow the user to perform
those database tasks without creating a
separate user for that it's a temporary
thing which allows to that and this has
become so powerful within amazon it
gives you so powerful so now you don't
need to create your own application
manage all the security even from your
mobile application directly you can call
database without bringing your app
server web server in picture
you can do this in a smart secure way
with amazon identity federation part
now you say that's all good
do you think what's any additional
security does amazon provide
and that's where amazon offers a service
called
multi-factor authentication
multifactor means there are two level of
authentications
instead of one
here normally you log into your aws
account you would be login with a
username and password
here you log in with a username
password and
a token if you have known the vpn token
vpn for
exactly the same thing it does
it provides one more level of
authentication and using that you would
be able to log into your aws resources
so it adds an additional layer of
security in addition to your username
and password
advantage is this token can be generated
by your mobile application also
there is application called google
authenticator which works with the
android and ios both phones and even
windows phones also you can download
that application
sync it with your aws account now
anytime you want to login to amazon
account you would be able to log in with
your username password
and it would enforce you to provide this
six digit code
to ensure you have a secure access to
resources
let's see some of the best practices
offered by amazon
and
that's a murder mystery
murder in the cloud
i was just talking about the mfa and
there is a case this case has happened
and you can always google on
murder in the aws cloud and you would
find this infoward article
which says story about the
codespaces.com
a couple of years back
codespaces.com was one of the most
popular website
for the developers they were sharing the
codes repository everything over there
they were hosted on amazon because every
startup they would have all the
advantages
one thing which they did not take care
of
was a security
they did not take care of the security
and they were not using these roles they
were not using im users they were not
using multi-factor authentication they
did not follow the amazon security
standards
and what happened
somebody got hold of their account
with its username password or the keys
they someone got hold of that
and he literally hijacked the account
whether he or she i don't know
hijacked the account and asked the
ransom
from
codespaces.com before codespaces could
take certain
preventive actions they tried to
approach amazon before they could solve
this
the hijacker deleted the all the
production servers
hijacker deleted all the backup files
also
edited everything which was there
and that said made the code space to die
it literally killed the code spaces now
you can see that's why you can see it's
a domain is for sale
because
the one which was the best
place for the developers
is got killed because they did not take
the
enough precautions or measures for the
security
and that's why you need to follow
certain best practices for that
you have to define your security
strategy
and assign credentials accordingly
never never never use your root account
create each and every individual user
and give them the access i tell you my
story
i used to manage
20 30 plus aws accounts myself
but i still never used myself amazon
root account root account means with the
login id username email password i
always created
an im user and login with that
because i know
if someone gets my username password by
any group i don't want to go and fall
into that trap you can log into my
account and kill everything
instead of creating an individual user
level policy always define a policy set
a group level it's easy to manage
and it's a powerful also because if you
would forget if you have to change the
policy for 50 users that would not work
for you it's a tiresome rather do it at
one user level only
do not open permission
for all
rather be restrictive
do not give everyone all the kind of
access this is not the world where you
donate everything
this is the world where you collect
everything and
as per is
eligibility criteria you assign him the
permissions
you should also assign some kind of a
password policy at your organization
level iam also supports that
always use multi-factor authentication
as an added level of security
never use keys and
while storing the data inside your aws
account or code rather use i am roles
when you want to share the access like
with the different accounts use i am
roles
always keep track of your activity what
you are doing you should always track
that amazon also offers a service called
cloud trail which always helps you what
are you accessing or not
so that's why if i want to summarize
this
i am is a powerful tool
to manage secure access of amazon
resources
it's very easy to use so
in our tech essential course we do all
the demos and everything where we will
be able to show you how you work with
that
and once you create that
it's very easy to manage also but if you
did not
manage it properly you open all the
permissions it will create problems also
so that's why it's always advisable you
understand your security need define
your used cases and implement the
policies accordingly
these are some of the reference we have
used for this
slides i hope this would be helpful for
you also
and i open forum for the question and
answer i hope you all had a wonderful
time
thanks for listening to me and this is
i'm opening for now any questions you
have
that was fantastic thank you for that
it's it's it's always so great to see
one of those horror story examples too
of uh what happens when you don't take
the proper precautions
can imagine
losing everything the way that those
poor people did
we do have a couple of questions queued
up uh that i've got offline here but
before we do that
i'm going to ask everybody to indulge me
for about 60 seconds here while i take
over the screen
and i'm going to show you all a quick
poll
this is a public-facing webinar so this
webinar of course is is available for
anybody to attend uh whether or not they
are currently
training with simply learn or if you
simply heard about this webinar through
a friend or through a social posting or
what have you
and that's great we love having
everybody here it's our way to give back
to the community and help folks get
these kinds of insights from our subject
matter experts to advance their careers
we do a dozen or more of these every
month in a variety of disciplines across
aws i.t security data science project
management six sigma digital marketing
all across
a variety of skill sets but our core
service just so folks know is more than
just these webinars we are a business
and technology training provider here at
simply learn we have over 400 web-based
training courses in a wide variety of
these professional skill sets
and most of these courses are accredited
by over 40 of the third-party uh
recognized third-party certifying bodies
like prince2 and pmi and omcp in the
open group and so forth
we developed these trainings
specifically to prepare you for the
certification exams from those third
parties and we base our training
materials on the very latest body of
knowledge that is prescribed by those
organizations and all of this
is designed and presented by our faculty
of very experienced and professional
trainers and working professionals uh
like tarun
so when you join these training training
webinars training programs rather what
you get is a complete structured course
all the information and the resources
and the hands-on and practical
experience that you're going to need
to hone your skills and successfully
pass that related certification test
in a lot of cases you'll get lab
exercises you'll get simulation exams
you might get access to additional
platforms or software where you can go
run experiments and do practice projects
and on top of all of that you also get
access to a very active moderated forum
you can interact directly with the
faculty and with other students ask
questions about the learning materials
or pose questions about how to address a
particular real world challenge that
you're having in your in your business
so it's a tremendous resource for folks
that want to really build and hone these
these professional skills to really set
themselves apart in what is obviously
becoming a more and more competitive
world for uh folks with these kinds of
technical skill sets so if you're
interested in learning more about the
training beyond the webinars if you tick
the appropriate box we'll have somebody
get back in touch with you there's no
obligation but you'll get a chance to
maybe see the back end of the system and
look at what the learning platform uh
operates like
and we can give you a little guidance to
help figure out which course
series might be appropriate to meet the
goals that you have for honing your
skills and improving your your career
your business so thanks for indulging me
i wanted to make sure everybody
understood that there was more beyond
the webinars i'm going to close this
poll down here now and uh we'll go back
to tarun's screen
and that's that's all i have to say
about that
thank you sir i've got a couple of quick
questions here we've got just a few
minutes left before the end of the hour
i'll tackle the first question which is
always the most common is there a
recording of this webinar available and
or can i get a hold of the slide deck
and the quick answer to that is yes we
record all of our webinars and they are
edited down and produced and put into
the simply learned site the timeline
depends on the production team's
schedule
if they're focused on new training
courses of course which we always are
those take precedence but we get these
webinars recordings up as quickly as we
can and also keep an eye on the youtube
channel more and more we're seeing uh
this kind of material pushed up there as
well so if you haven't done that yet you
can go to youtube and subscribe to the
simply learn channel you'll get notified
when new videos are added up there
tyrone uh
quick question here with regard to the
comparison between aws versus google
cloud is there a significant security
benefit to aws over google
i would say yes the reason is
though they both are the best of the
resources available in the market
but the amazon has done all the kind of
a certifications so you think of that
whether it's either 27001 sox1 sox2
compliance pci dss or the europe
compliance or the cloud security
alliance you think of those all the kind
of a certification amazon is having
apart from that amazon provides lots of
kind of encryption secure data
things they also ensure the security of
the data also within their organization
also so they have taken much more better
security measures in top of that you
have a service like i am roles which i
don't see available in google and that's
why i would rate amazon as much better
in the security aspect than google but i
won't say google is less but yes amazon
is having much better offerings here
very interesting i'm surprised by that
at google i would imagine that they're
going to have to play some catch up if
uh if they
if they want to stay playing the game
and and be sure and install that those
roles like that
right right and to tell you frankly
uh gartner releases their magic quadrant
for the infertility service every year
the july quadrant is expected anytime
they just released for the storage
service only the major iws is yet to
come but amazon is leader over there
since five years
google was in visionary till yes last
year
and they started coming to the leaders
quadrant since last year
i hope they would catch a little bit but
they are still much far further the
nearest competitor to amazon is
microsoft first for the gartner the
nearest competitor is microsoft the
amazon is undisputed king the second
would be the
microsoft and third would be the google
the thing that seems so beautiful about
the amazon system is the scalability of
it being able to start so small and very
granular and so inexpensively uh and
particularly as you said for for
you know startups and small
organizations that just need to test the
waters
such a great way to get access to uh you
know so much secure resources uh at a
relatively low cost or as you said free
early on right when you're just playing
with it
exactly
uh is is aws cloud a career path
appropriate to people that want to work
as private contractors as consultants or
are more of the opportunities on
in-house teams at an enterprise or
level
it's one of the best career path right
now
so some of the service recently shows
that in usa
the average salary of a cloud architect
cloud consultant is almost hundred and
ten thousand dollars i'm saying almost
and that's an average only i'm talking
about
and that's growing every year the demand
of aws is growing a lot over there
frankly
i just being a consultant myself i get
multiple requirements every week for the
various kind of a need people are having
on amazon because amazon is widely
accepted across the globe not only
usa or europe now it's india china
everywhere
amazon is widely accepted and that's why
the demand is spiking a lot a lot so
it's one of the best carry option you
can think of
that's
that's good to know it gives people much
more flexibility in terms of what to do
with their careers and you don't have to
sit around and wait for an in-house
position
somewhere
because there's such a demand for the
skill set you can make your own schedule
and pick your own clients that's
fantastic um
one last question i've got here uh with
regard to professional conferences and
and so forth is there a professional
conference
uh
specifically for aws and cloud where
people can meet other practitioners uh
and hear about trends in the industry
that you would recommend that they might
attend
right so one of the best event is aws
re invent that happens every
october last week or november i believe
it's in november uh i might not be exit
but you can always get the dates from
the amazon's website
that is where the whole world of the aws
whose and user would come and
participate there there would be
hundreds of sessions going in parallel
that is one of the best place where you
meet the people
socially connect with them this is the
place for you so i would recommend for
the people to go for that event for them
that would be the best part
second thing would be you can always
think of that there would be lots of the
amazon has started the different
events online also so there are lots of
online events you can just go and
register over there you would be
learning a lot about amazon amazon is
having its own youtube channel also
where you can three lots of past
webinars also
apart from that amazon keeps on doing
the lofts also regularly across the
country so you can participate that
there are lots of events happening at
the amazon level you could always check
out those
i just found the link for the reinvent
and i shared that into the chat folks so
if you want to see that uh link in your
chat module you can click on that and
get that into your browser it looks like
it's uh november 28th to december 2nd
this year
uh right that's the date i just opened
it perfect yeah there you go
so you and i are looking at the same
screen now so uh yep that's that seems
like a great place to uh to go to uh
find out about the
the resources in the conference and
and uh see what you can do to get
yourself there that that's fantastic
um
i've got a couple of other links that
i'm going to share into uh the chat
module for folks to to
click out and take a look at
one of them uh i i've got a couple of
links here for shortcuts to some of the
courses on simplylearn on aws security
and aws in general so take a look at
those links
there that'll shortcut you into the
beginning of a search into our system
and uh
the other thing is
a listing of all of the uh resources
available
by specialty and upcoming webinars uh by
specialty and again i shortcuted you
this shortcutted a word i shortcut you
to
a a search on aws and of course you can
also click around in that section of the
site and find resources on a lot of
different
technical
specialties
including aws and beyond
and i see there tyrone you've found the
sessions
on aws uh re invent
right there 123 sessions going to happen
across three days
so it's the one place you should be
no kidding and you better spend some
time figuring out your schedule ahead of
time because there's no way you're going
to get to all 123 sessions so there's a
lot to choose from there
but pick and choose the ones that are of
most interest to you and what a what a
great resource that is
uh and we are at 9 00 30 my time we've
used up our hour so uh thank you
so much tyrone for being here and for
sharing that that's
incredibly uh
thorough and very granular uh actionable
uh recommendations for folks in your
presentation
very much thanks a lot
and thanks everyone for joining hope you
all had a wonderful time and hope to see
some of you
to take essential course
absolutely and uh with that said join us
for another webinar real soon everybody
thank you for taking time out of your
day or your evening to be here with us
and now to get back to work or get back
to sleep depending on where you are uh
nicole says thank you very much tyrone
it was very engaging
all right everybody have a terrific rest
of your day or your evening and until we
see you next time take care of
yourselves bye-bye
you